Greece is broke and O's European
governments and banks hundreds of
billions of dollars for years these
governments have made the Greeks adopt
austerity measures massive public
spending cuts and higher taxes in
exchange they've given it more loans to
pay off the existing debt but it's not
really working austerity has made Greece
much poorer meaning it can't raise more
money to pay off those debts so it needs
more loans which are given only in
return for more austerity the Greek
people have now said no to this cycle
and their government is hoping it can
use the vote to negotiate better terms
basically Greece will be telling its
lenders if you respect democracy and
still want your money back you'll make
it easier for us to let our economy grow
if a deal can't be reached then Greece
will probably keep defaulting on its
loans it could be thrown out of the euro
it won't pay back its debts but it will
run out of money that's called
insolvency and a country that doesn't
pay back its debts won't be able to
borrow any more money but those who
voted no to austerity are hoping they'll
be able to recover in a few years the
only thing anyone really knows is Greeks
are in for more tough times before the
global financial crisis Greece paid off
its debt the same way many other
countries did by borrowing even more
money after the crisis hit banks became